il ya une idée qui était dans le rapport
terra nova de 2011 qui est aujourd'hui
largement partagé aussi par tout un tas
d'intellectuels de gauche qui est cette
idée c'est quoi c'est qu'il ya une
droitisation de la société il ya une
droitisation des classes populaires et
du coup on en déduit quoi on en déduit
que les forces politiques de gauche doit
s'aligner sur cette société qui s'est
droitisée mais ça c'est largement
contestable vous avez moi je suis
politiste sociologue vous avez tout un
tas de travaux qui gagnerait à être
consultés davantage qui montre que c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça vous avez
toujours eu déjà une partie des classes
populaires qui était à droite c'est un
phénomène qui est vieux comme la classe
ouvrière ça c'est le premier point
deuxième point cette grande idée que
avec le tournant disons centriste néo
libérale du ps et même en partie des
communistes vous auriez comme ça des
électeurs qui était à gauche qui sont
passés à l'extrême droite ça c'est
marginal quand on regarde bien les
chiffres de manière précise c'est
complètement résiduelles ce qui s'est
passé c'est que les classes sociales les
groupes sociaux qui votait pour la
gauche encore dans les années 70-80
aujourd'hui se sont réfugiés dans
l'abstention est pas dans le vote
d'extrême droite quand on le prétend
aujourd'hui donc comment est-ce qu'on
s'adresse à ces gens-là pas en mettant
le doigt dans l'engrenage dé obsession
identitaire et raciste de la droite et
de l'extrême droite et il ya un dernier
point que je voudrais mentionner sait
aussi qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes à
gauche qui résonne avec l'idée que les
classes populaires c'est forcément la
figure de du petit blanc vous savez le
petit blanc qui vit en zone rurale qui
est craintif et et haineux envers les
étrangers mais les classes populaires
aujourd'hui elles sont beaucoup plus
complexes elles sont beaucoup plus
diversifiée que ça les classes
populaires aujourd'hui c'est la
caissière c'est la femme de ménage c'est
des jeunes diplômés mais très précaire
c'est beaucoup d'immigrés parce qu'on
oppose comme ça il y aurait le feu
social et le sociétal y aurait les
ouvriers et les immigrés mais excusez
moi mais plein d'ouvriers sont immigrées
plein d'immigrés sont ouvriers fin donc
on a comme ça des espèces de façon très
binaire très manichéenne de
d'appréhender les groupes sociaux qui à
mon avis font beaucoup de mal à la fin
c'est pas seulement que ces
problématiques intellectuellement c'est
que politiquement ensuite ça nous mène
dans des impasses
[Musique]